welcome back to las vegas now silver
state schools credit union the sponsors
of this next segment offers premier
financial services to their members and
mercedes sat down with president and ceo
scott r kills to find out more
i love telling everyone how i'm a member
of silver state schools credit union and
what's cool is you don't have to be an
educator or a student to join however
you sure do love your educators over
there
absolutely
this is one of my favorite subjects
because it because it really talks about
how inclusive we are so you know silver
state schools credit union loves
educators because ssscu was actually
founded by seven educators in 1951
and this small group of visionaries
really endeavored to create a credit
union that delivered excellent member
service and for over 70 years in fact we
just celebrated our 71st year
solar city schools credit union has
built a foundation of providing
excellent products services and benefits
to uh
really to become the premier financial
services institution for our members and
for the las vegas community
now while we were originally founded by
educators anyone can become a member uh
if you do not meet the basic membership
qualifications through an education
institution uh and whether that's
through employment or enrollment
but if you enroll in vegas pbs and you
can qualify for a membership right away
and begin to reap the benefits of silver
state schools credit union membership
which we think is pretty special we've
won the best of las vegas uh credit
union for the last four years in a row
so uh we think we've got a great thing
here and uh and we'd love to to share
our services with other members it
really is great and when you walk in you
feel like you're a part of a family and
i've never experienced that at a
financial institution before so it is
such a great family to be a part of and
let's talk about some of the great
services a lot of members right now
may be trying to buy a home or maybe
they want to take advantage of the
equity that they have in their home
right now how can silver state schools
credit union help with that yeah that's
a good great question silver state
schools credit union is really here to
help our members in the community
realize their dream of things like home
ownership for example and taking
advantage of the many benefits that
homeownership provides you know um you
can build equity in your home that's a
big thing in the in in our market
because our equity values have really
really gone up and so that's why we've
got licensed mortgage experts here to
help you finance a new home and we have
24-hour pre-approvals which is pretty
darn fast uh conventional jumper jumbo
home loan programs down payment options
fast closings and our exclusive home
advantage program um nine times out of
ten mercedes we're going to close a loan
on a home loan or home equity loan a lot
faster than anybody else and
so we can also assist with assessing
your uh current home's equity to
refinance or uh an existing mortgage uh
to complete with your home improvements
um you know maybe consolidate high
interest that pay for college expenses i
know you've got that coming up with your
daughter
and uh and also purchasing large ticket
items and so again our mortgage experts
are happy to discuss your financial
needs and help you achieve your home
ownership goals
it's easy to uh visit us at
silverstatecu.com
mortgage
thanks again to silver state schools
credit union for sponsoring that segment
call 702-733-8820
for more information we'll be right back